hey guys it's fadee with maxtec and we
have literally been waiting almost
10 years for this moment the redesigned
imac
and this video is not just going to be a
simple unboxing
we're going to be comparing this to the
imac
and the imac pro in terms of everything
from the design
the physical dimensions the webcams the
speakers the microphones
everything including the performance as
well so
let's go ahead let's unbox this all
right let's get this on the side
wow this thing oh my goodness oh
that's so lightweight oh that's insane
got our
keyboard nice let's grab
all of this stuff out of here i got most
of this unboxed i got the keyboard
got the mouse the power adapter with the
brick the power cable but now this is
the moment of truth
we have the blue 24 inch imac and i
really want to see
how this looks because a lot of people
have been talking about it
so this is gonna be the reveal
[Applause]
wow that blue color guys this is an imac
unboxing like we have literally never
seen
before wow look at
that that is a nice finish oh my
goodness
oh and that apple logo it's like a nice
like plastic oh man that's nice
and of course on this side you got the
hello text
let's look at those white bezels
wow a lot of people were dissing on
these white bezels but
man it actually looks pretty nice and of
course guys since this is a comparison i
have the
27 inch imac the intel right here
unfortunately we don't have the 21.5
inch because we never had that because
it sucked
but this thing is going to be nice so i
want to compare some things guys
of course we have the color matched
accessories got the blue magic mouse the
blue keyboard
the blue power cable and like wow this
magnetic connector that is so unique
even the inside of the connector is blue
that is just crazy of course we have the
power adapter which we did not have
because it's on the inside of the old
intel max
and this one actually does have the
ethernet jack so that's kind of cool
that they can do that
and route it through the power supply
now the first thing i want to do before
we get into the imacs themselves
is compare the accessories so as you can
see here's the blue and here's the
original
silver and as you can tell it's pretty
nice
looks like they chose to go with those
uh light blue
rubber pads instead of black here but
other than that man they're
basically identical no real difference
between these two
but now if we move on to the keyboards
the edges are much more
rounded and because of that the keys
themselves and the corners
are rounded as well and the big new
thing here is
touch id right here replacing this
useless eject key
that we never ever use so useless we now
have touch id so we're going to be
testing that out a little bit later and
see how it works
but i definitely say that i like this
blue and we do get some new keys as well
right here we have some blank keys that
were never used on this imac but now we
have this search key
the microphone we have do not disturb
the media keys
all of that is new we have the new
language globe
emoji key right there so definitely some
differences
but not that big of a differences all
right now let's compare the imacs
themselves
and i know this is the 27 inch but this
is gonna help you see
how thin and light this thing is like
look at this
easy like super light but
in terms of the thinness dude this is so
heavy
it's so heavy compared to the apple
silicon model but let's put these
together
and if you can look at the top camera
you can see
how incredibly thin that 24 inch
is oh my goodness look at how thick this
27 inch intel imac is that's nuts and
you can also see
the stand size much different and
another thing i noticed is that the
thickness of the chin is actually
basically identical on both of these
except that they did choose to get rid
of the apple logo which is kind of weird
but it's definitely minimalistic it
definitely looks good
now on the back there are definitely
some huge differences we have these air
vents
that are gone on the back of the 24 inch
image they're just not there
we also have this ram access slot on the
27 inch
that is also gone the ram is now
soldered on you are not going to be able
to replace it yourself what's cool about
the 24 inch is that the
exhaust vents and the speaker vents are
all
on this strip on the bottom so it's
really nice and clean
and also take a look at these two strips
the rubber pads
this is different compared to the old
imacs and it actually matches
the leaked renders the leaked cad files
that uh john prosser showed off
on the new macbook air that's supposed
to be coming later so that's
kind of nice and just to show you guys
the bottom of the imac we had these
vents as well and you can see that the
design for the rubber pad strip
was different compared to the new one so
yeah pretty interesting now the last
thing i want to show you guys is the
difference in apple logos
they had like a metallic chrome apple
logo here and they totally went to a
different
kind of like plastic insert that's very
light
and the apollo is obviously much larger
on this one compared to the old one
and i'd say like i really like the look
of this this looks really good now the
one thing that's a little bit
disappointing with the new one
is the ports as you can see right here
we have a wide selection
we have the sd card we have the
headphone jack we have four usb a's
and of course we have two thunderbolts
and the ethernet
compared to just four usbcs with two of
them being thunderbolt so it kind of
sucks to lose those other ports
especially the sd card slot but we do
have
right here on the side we have the
headphone jack so that's still pretty
nice
and the last finishing touch that i love
on the 24 inch is the new magnetic
power cable i'm going to show you guys
the old method
which definitely was kind of tough you'd
have to plug it in like that
but the worst part was unplugging it
like you got to pull and yank it out
definitely a bit annoying on the old
intel max but check this out
one-handed just like that easy magnetic
and hey wow you actually have to pull
pretty hard definitely easier on that
thing but
with one hand you can plug it in and
unplug it
definitely nice and convenient and i
don't think you're gonna unplug it on
accident and one thing that i just
noticed while plugging these in
the power cable on the 24 inch is like
twice as long as this
this is a little bit annoying if you're
trying to plug in somewhere further away
so that's
really convenient and there we go we are
powered on and we are greeted with all
of this hello text
for the first sign-on that's awesome
apple just
killed it with this thing we're going
through the setup and we are now at the
touch id section
as you can see so let's go ahead hit
continue and
it's working just fine just just like
it's always
been no issues at all and now that we're
fully set up let's do the comparison and
we're going to be getting into things
like the speakers the webcams and the
performance i do want to mention that
this is the
1700 model that means it has the 16 gigs
of ram it has the 8 core gpu and of
course it has the touch of the magic
keyboard and the ethernet so that's the
updated model
and this right here is the 2020 27 inch
imac
and it's for 2300 it has the 5500
xt graphics it has the 3.8 gig
eight core i7 and it has 64 gigs of ram
that we upgraded ourselves
but anyway it's 1700 versus 2300 plus
the ram
so let's go ahead and run some tests and
compare them and the first test we're
doing
is the blackmagic disk speed test to
test the speed
of the ssd alright so 2300 on the right
and it's looking like 2 800 on the read
and then over here we have 2200 on the
right
and 2100 on the read so we are
definitely getting
improved read speeds on the m1 which is
really nice
and now let's get into the cpu
performance we're going to be testing
out geekbench
5. all right we've got our scores and
this is actually really impressive
17 43 for the single core compared to
1269
on the 2300 imac that's 37
faster single core performance and it's
even faster than the imac
pros single core performance as well and
then if we look at multi-core
this imac is actually faster because it
has an eight core that's eight high
performance cores
and it's an i7 so we're getting 8 800
compared to
7400 and surprisingly
this m1 imac is not that far off from
the imac
pro so that's really good performance
for
300 if you're gonna get the base model
but of course we have the 1700
model and now let's go ahead and test
the graphics performance
but before we do that you are going to
time travel into the future and you are
going to listen to the speaker
and the webcam and microphone comparison
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i just listened to those speakers and
honestly i'm a little bit underwhelmed
with the volume of the 24 inch imac
like the sound quality is really really
good everything's nice
crisp clear the highs and vocals are
really really good
but the volume on even the 27 inch is
much much louder and then going to the
imac
pro it's a massive difference and the
bass on the imac pro is just
insane especially compared to this so
while i might say that the quality is
the best on the 24 inch
it's just missing that volume that i
really like this is the webcam and
microphone quality on the 2020
27 inch imac with the 720p facetime
camera
this is the microphone and webcam
quality on the 2017
27 inch imac pro with the 1080p
facetime camera and this is a webcam and
microphone quality on the 2021
24-inch imac with the 1080p facetime
camera
and the m1 isp welcome back to the
performance testing let's go ahead
and start that metal graphics geekbench
test all right we have our scores back
and we have around 22
000 metal points on the 24 inch imac and
42
000 on the intel imac now of course
that's because that's the 27 inch model
and this 24 inch is in no way meant to
replace it
we are expecting m1x imax to come later
this year and the performance is going
to be killer
more than what you're seeing here and
compared to the imac pro
it's 2.4 times faster than this 24 inch
imac but what can you expect
this still gives you really great
performance now before i get into the
real world tests i do want to check out
speedometer
that's a browser benchmark now if you're
getting this 24-inch imac
mainly for web browsing a little bit of
productivity and stuff like that
web browsing is extremely important to
you guys so let's go ahead and
run this web browsing test and see what
performance we get
that is what i call killer browsing
performance 226 compared to 163 that is
38 faster web browsing performance
that's going to be awesome for a lot of
you guys
because this imac is gonna feel much
more snappy
than this one and this is definitely
cheaper and on top of that because the
ssd
is faster it's gonna feel snappy much
more snappy than that one and because
the ssd is also
faster that's going to add on to it even
more especially since you have apple
silicon
which is like in line with apple
software much better than
all the drivers and other intel issues
you have to deal with
with this guy now let's move on to a
real world
gaming test this is gfx bench metal so
let's start the 1440p
aztec ruins high tier offscreen test on
each of these and see if we have a
difference in graphics performance
all right this is very interesting we
have 81 fps
on the 24 inch and we have 135.6 fps
on the 27-inch imac now that's
interesting because
in geekbench metal this imac was 90
faster but now it's only 67
faster that means that the unified
architecture or something else
is making it more efficient for gaming
and now let's move on to cinebench r23
this is the real cpu stress test and
we're not going to do the 10 minute one
we're just going to do the single test
because i don't want to sit there for
that long we got stuff to do we have
ipad pros
to test as well so if you are not
already subscribed
do so right now because we have the 8
gig and the 16 gig version of the new m1
ipad pro
and that is going to be interesting guys
i don't know if you can hear this
but the fan on the intel imac is
chugging along it's going
while the m1 is literally silent i can't
hear
anything at all right here we have our
scores back and no wonder the fan was
kicking because this imac is
64 faster in cinebench that is a
huge difference this imex still getting
about 7 700 points which is really good
i mean it's faster than the 16 inch
macbook pro
but it does not compare to this 27 inch
which we really didn't expect it to but
in real world performance tests which
i'm not going to test right now
but we tested the m1 mac mini and
comparing the m1 mac mini to
the imac and the imac pro it actually
did
really well in a lot of the different
tests because you have the updated and
new encoders
and you have a bunch of other stuff like
the unified memory
that makes it perform very well
especially in
xcode where it was even faster than our
mac pro
so in real world tests the m1 24 inch
imac
is still going to be killer so there you
guys go that was all of the testing
between the 24 inch and the 27 inch imac
and the imac pro in terms of the
performance
and i've got to say for 1300
or 1700 like this one you are really
getting a lot of value because that 4.5
k display
is really nice you're getting this
really nice and new design
you're getting the colors you're getting
everything you're getting that m1 chip
which is super efficient
and it works so well especially for web
browsing
and that ssd performance so i've got to
say that i'm really happy
with this and i would probably choose
the 24 inch imac
over this 2300 27 inch imac
except if you really need that graphics
performance or the extra cpu performance
if you
absolutely need that then maybe you
would still get one of these guys
or an upgraded version but if you just
need a basic computer and you are going
to be doing some productivity work
but not all the time then i would still
go for this 24 inch because
this design is not going to change for
years and that's going to help it keep
the resale value up compared to this 27
inch which is going to be going out of
style
extremely soon especially when the
larger 30 inch
m1x imac comes so so hopefully you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did
click the circle above to subscribe
because we have those other m1 ipad pro
videos coming soon
definitely check out one of those two
videos right there thanks for watching
and we'll see you in the next video